it was announced that you'll be starring
in a Yellowstone spin-off show
what do you think about the uh Cowboy
ethos that permeates Yellowstone and
other shows created by Taylor Sheridan
you're a Texan I'm a Texan yeah what do
you think about that like philosophy and
way of life
I admire the Simplicity of it
I mean one bit one way you could explain
Yellowstone and a
Costa's role is what
um what will man do to protect land and
family
in a world that's trying to encroach
in a world where
there's a Cabo ethos that deems
trespassing more clear
earlier yeah
than other other hats
um
I admire that simplicity
of right and wrong
and that the the Simplicity of that
right and wrong doesn't always uh
correlate coincide with the law nope
it's above the law
it's you mentioned something earlier I
remember where it was in conversation
but it was a little bit of like careful
law and handling this I am yeah
yeah and then it is
the Law's not going to handle this
therefore I am
and then it is I'm handling this
law
talk to them when you get to them I'm
handling this
there's a honesty to that it just seems
of course it's dangerous because uh it's
a slippery slope uh that because of the
power in that power corrupts it can be a
slippery slope where you completely
disregard the law and you can hurt a lot
of people
but when done right you know
there feels to be um
something really uh authentic and human
about that protect family protect land
Above All Else
yeah
but I you know
this is a broader question but I'm going
to piggyback it off this
back to the dreams and reality and then
evolved species and how long can we do
in creating a digital God an AI and
these communities and friends and
challenge us and think like us we like
to hang out with our
do you think we're less evolved
species than we give ourselves credit
for do you think we give ourselves
credit for being more involved
than we actually are
I think we do I do
I think we need to admit that
I think probably the cowboy ethos is a
as a step in towards admitting that
and that's why it's so appealing to
people
it kind of wakes them up to realize that
we are uh we're not so far
from our ancestors
that uh the values of loyalty are really
important
um
Trust
on the basic human level